[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are continuing what is
now the annual tradition
this would be the s third annual
yeah how do you do how do you do
anniversaries like that it's the third
time the third time the second update
uh of our let's see it's the third
anniversary the third anniversary of our
going public with our deconstruction
stories well it was two years ago
that's the two-year anniversary two year
see these numbers confuse me and i know
they confuse you
these engineering degrees man well we're
only talking about the numbers two or
three so come on let's pull this
together two years ago
we talked about
all of our spirituality leading up to
the present day
including our
spiritual deconstruction from
the the white evangelical church to be
very specific about it a lot of people
um
because we talk about it as a you know
our deconstruction anniversary or
whatever
that's not technically true because
right
some people think oh so two years ago
when you guys told your story you were
you were that was when you deconstructed
no as i mean as i've said many times my
deconstruction
happened about 10 years ago for me um
and you know i i stopped calling myself
a christian in 20
13 ish
um so that's getting close to a decade
of not being a christian
uh but it was it took us a long time to
gain the uh nerve to actually share that
yeah that happened two years ago
if you didn't listen to those or if you
want a refresher of it that series is
called the lost years it was four or
five episodes
you shared your story i shared my story
we also shared
all of our
you know our spiritual backgrounds
growing up our involvement in campus
crusade for christ as college students
our involvement as uh staff members
working full-time with crew
and then
we called it the lost years because that
was the part of our
career development that we that for
our up until that point we had not
talked about publicly which led into
talking about our spiritual
deconstruction speed or crosstalk yeah
you know the word deconstruct the
conquestion and then last year
and yeah so that was right before the
pandemic hit and then it just kind of
seemed like a year later we gave an
update so
we're gonna do that you know that
doesn't mean we only talk about
spiritual things once a year but
each year we want to give each of us an
opportunity to sort of say hey
this is where i'm at this is how i'm
contin continuing to process because the
process of
what's happening in our spiritual lives
is something that unfolds
uh and this is like the definitive
update
for for me we're gonna start with me and
next week we'll uh
we'll do links yeah i and i'm i'm
looking forward to this because
i mean
we see each other so often and we have
we're having so many conversations and
we're
you know we have so many so many things
come through our lives
that first of all make its way on the
show but second of all don't they're
more private that we still talk about
some of those things are spiritual in
nature
but there's always
seems to be like really pressing matters
and then just your life kind of gets
away from you so it's like we don't sit
down and talk for an hour an hour and a
half it's like hey give me your
spiritual
update you know it just kind of comes
out in bits and pieces
so i'm looking forward to hearing
more of this bonafide update um
and i i was about to say and i'm also
looking forward to giving mine but i'm
honestly not so we'll see well this
happens a week let's get started because
as you might imagine i've got quite a
lot to say yeah i'm all ears man now
i i'm always
i approach these the first one and the
second one and now the third one i
approach these with a certain amount of
trepidation because what i have found is
many of the things that i say during
these podcasts
are then uh sound bited sound bited
across the internet
through multiple platforms for people
who with people are bi people who agree
with me and people who don't agree with
me
um and so as i
calculate i end up writing down quite a
lot that i want to get to because i'm
trying to calculate what i'm going to
say because it will either be used
against me or it'll be yeah i
it is what it is but i'm just letting
you know i don't necessarily look
forward to this either because
these episodes there's a level of
scrutiny that that is applied to them
that i'm not exactly interested in
inviting but it is what it is and it is
now it just it's happening
annually i guess yeah there's a
heightened awareness of
and
of people listening in and different
groups of people listening and it's not
just you talking to me well we can get
lost in that conversation on
on a normal ear biscuit but and and also
you know
there's just weird balance with these
things are very personal
but yet we have a public platform where
we share personal things
that we
ha you know we've never really
um
we've talked about that and thought
about that but
there's a weirdness to that there's a
weirdness to this like okay i'm
experiencing these things and i'm in
process and i'm not i haven't come to
all these definitive conclusions or
anything but i'm
sharing them and i'm putting them out
into the world and then they are used by
other people to either form conclusions
make conclusions
to be
to combat other people's ideas defend
ideas that maybe i didn't even want to
be defended
it's just a weird there's a weird
dynamic to doing this
but let's not spend too much time
talking about that because i do have
quite a bit
there's a positive side too right i mean
there's a reason that you're ultimately
deciding to still do it
yeah yeah oh yeah i think that
the
response that we have gotten anytime
we've been vulnerable about these
spiritual things has been so encouraging
because they're this is a deeply
personal thing to millions and millions
billions most people on the earth and
most people in the history of the world
have had some sort of religious
conviction
that probably changed over time
and so when people talk about what their
religious convictions are their sort of
spiritual perspective and how it's
changed over time i think there's just a
it's part of the human experience
and
i i know for a fact that our story
resonates with a lot of people who have
come from a very similar background have
experienced similar things
and so
uh but again i i i don't do this i try
not to do this i have a my natural
disposition is to try to persuade and
try to convince i have an evangelistic
personality
i don't like that about myself
necessarily that's something i'm
actively trying to change
so that i can kind of get out of the
convincing business
as i get older
um
so this is more of hey this is what's
been going on with me
do with it what you will
um shoulder shrug okay so
at the end of last year the end of 2021
i actually told my wife i said uh
you know i
i kind of feel like i'm just
i don't have a huge appetite for
spiritual things right now like i just
don't
i maybe that's just not gonna be me
fast forward
to the beginning of this year so
literally just a few weeks ago
and i'm ordering a bible on amazon
okay so
just okay just to give you a little
preview not that i didn't have an amazon
bible is it jeff bezos like
a red red line edition what's that
amazon uh what's the ben franklin bible
what's the amazon brand for like
batteries
what i don't know what do you call the
batteries i would say kirkland that's
the
no there's more you don't get the amazon
batteries
amazon basics yeah i got the
amazonbasics bible
no you didn't no i you'll understand why
i got a bible uh i already had plenty of
bibles but why i got a specific bible
okay
just a little tease just a little t so
uh how did i get here okay so
since deconstructing and really
deconverting you know i didn't just
deconstruct i deconverted i'm not a
christian anymore
um which has been almost a decade for me
i have dabbled in a lot of spiritual
things right spiritual and quotes
just
but that kind that has all kind of
happened outside of any sort of system
you know i haven't
i like i didn't like oh i want to see
what buddhism feels like like officially
you know i i've read a lot of
interesting stuff and i've read a lot of
spiritual writers i've been really
attracted to people who kind of take
western and eastern philosophies and
kind of bridge them bring them together
people like eckhart tolle like i've been
very encouraged and there's been some
realizations that i've had while reading
spiritual writers
i'm not going to go into what all that
has has been but it's been significant
and it has been
characterized more as realization rather
than revelation right so i make that
distinction that these are more
realizations than revelations because
revelation is something that feels like
you're getting something from somewhere
else like you're literally getting
uh something revealed to you by god
you know it hasn't been anything on that
level it's more like epiphanies like oh
never thought about that but that
applies to something that i can only
apply only describe as spirituality i
know that's pretty
amorphous but
but i have stopped short of going too
deep into anything right
because
the more structured and systematic
a
spiritual
system gets the more suspect i become of
it right
so take for instance you know we live in
in in los angeles so we're in southern
california where if there is a religion
of this region it is new ageism in in
general right
uh people who
buy crystals because they think that the
crystals have specific spiritual powers
or whatever and bring certain you know
like there's literally like a
metaphysical
power to these crystals like you leave
it in the moonlight to charge it with
energy right
lots of people as you can imagine
here on the west coast believe this you
might trip on a curb and land in a
crystal shop yeah now i don't believe
that it's true like you know it might be
but
in many ways it
begins to resemble the same sort of like
metaphysical convictions about things
that you can't really be sure about that
i ran away from when it comes to
fundamentalist christianity or
conservative christianity yeah and so
i'm just really suspect of systems so
i'm not about to become like hey i'm the
new age guy and i've got this crystal
around my neck that's giving me this
spirit of clarity
again
i'm not saying definitively that that's
not true
because what i am saying is that i can't
believe that
you know i am incapable of believing
that
because there's something about me that
makes me incapable of buying into
something that it feels like you've
taken a bridge too far
like you've like you got up to a certain
place like you followed rationality and
lodge it to a certain place
and then you had to make a big jump into
some metaphysical reality and when you
make that jump i'm kind of like cool
if that's good for you that's great but
i don't think i can go there with you
because there's just something built
into me that causes me to i get up
against this wall and i'm like i can't
go there even if it seems fun i can't do
that i can't go there
but the interesting thing i thought you
might but
you determine that you can't um
well okay
i kind of i've been very wary of uh
leaving i don't think you ever thought
you might leaving one religious system
i didn't think that the next stage was
joining another religious system yeah
um
but the interesting thing is that my
search for
purpose
meaning
has never waned in the process
so even though
i became very unsure about what i what
my world view is in terms of how i think
about spiritual things and whether or
not god exists and if god does exist
what is the nature of god what is the
nature of god's interaction with me as a
person
how real can it be how substantive
substantial can it be
substantive i think is the word i was
looking for
i have never i i feel like i can't draw
conclusions about those things but i
haven't lost
i didn't i didn't say and none of it
matters and i'm not interested in it
i've what i realized is that there is
what i would call a religious
disposition in my personality at the
same time okay so this so this is
you know so talking about that
my desire for purpose and meaning never
really waning
that's why i was such a
serious christian to begin with right
that's why and i think i speak for you
in this in in this as well
that's why i was
really all about my faith in high school
when my friends started being all about
partying and sex and everything else the
stuff i was thinking about but
i was really like no man if this is true
if it is true
that jesus is the connection to god
jesus is god and
there is a spiritual reality that exists
if that is true that's way more
important than
friday night
you know that's way more important than
having a good time and so
my life has been chara my religious life
when i was spiritually a christian and
a current conservative christian
you know i took it very very seriously
and it's why
college was characterized by just being
involved in a campus ministry and
basically my entire social life and all
my activities being centered around that
going on staff with campus crusade with
you after we graduated basically
becoming missionaries training people to
share jesus throughout the world because
it was the most important thing that
there was
yeah i you know it was it was a very
simple
logical argument that resonated with
both of us and
i think i'll end up talking
about i know i'll end up talking about
my story next week so i'm not going to
do that here but just
exploring the why
for me has
starting to do that has been
enlightening
you know i i think it
yes it resonates
with my personality and your personality
in in in different ways but to a similar
result of like being
uh
being very fervent
almost being like a zealot like we were
like high school zealots yeah um it was
also something that was
very um
indoctrinated is is is an aggressive
word but we were we were strongly
educated in these it was drilled into us
you know so i wonder like what
do you understand what it is about
yourself that
like even now with more distance
that
made you latch on to it because i don't
know if it's the same reasons for you as
for me like
i don't know i don't i i don't know
i and i i'm not i'm not but when it
comes to ideas and it comes to like
right and wrong is something that very
much resonated with both of us i just
don't know if they're for the same
reasons i think that that
again i may be just being right i may be
deceiving myself
but the thing that i have always thought
is that
whatever is true
no matter how uncomfortable it is
i've had this
inescapable draw to it
meaning that it's the principle by which
you you you've
you've
you've had this instinctual draw to it
but you've also had this
logical assertion that like this is the
principle that i'm living by this is the
highest
principle
to live by and yeah we definitely for
whatever reason
something being true
whether or not it's true makes all the
difference in the world to me right
again i'm not saying i'm some perfect
perfect rational being i i'm a product
of my environment my circumstances and
my genetics just like anybody else but
for whatever reason
that combination of factors has led to a
place where
if something ends up not being true it
becomes very difficult for me to believe
for convenient reasons
but it also puts you on a it sets up a
moral high ground that's like could
potentially be like a superiority thing
it's like i know we both took pride and
keep going though um
so
i've retained this religious disposition
i've retained this
for lack of a better word skepticism
right and in fact that that skepticism
that was like if this is
you know what is true is the most
important thing it's ultimately how
seriously i took my faith is the reason
for me that i deconstructed
right because because because i kept
going back to the foundations and i kept
going back and said okay i'm really i'm
putting everything out i'm leveraging so
much on this so much is rooted in this
if this is not true so i would go back
and i would try to make it true and if i
was introduced to new information that
seemed like it couldn't fit i would find
a way for it to
fit or i would find a way to push it
away and it was this constant battle of
reorganizing rearranging my faith
relaying that foundation making sure the
foundation i was like constantly
inspecting the building of my faith and
being like oh there's a little crack
there let's let's you know let's replace
those bricks whatever
and then of course you know the story
i've already told that story i got to a
place where i could not the foundation
itself was made out of the wrong
material is what i thought
and i basically demolished the whole
building i deconstructed that that's
where the whole idea comes from right
you're tearing it down
but i've realized that there's been
these two parallel
seemingly conflicting
forces in my life for a really long time
uh and that is my
relentless skepticism
and then my persistent desire for
ultimate meaning
those two things
just refuse to die right
and so
you know
they've been in my personality
in kind of relative conflict for a long
time
but
i think the i'll call it an epiphany
that's probably too strong of a word but
i'll call it an epiphany the thing that
i've realized you call it an epiphany
this this year
is that
it's just asking the question what if i
don't deny either my skepticism or my
spirituality those so simplifying those
terms what if they can inform and
enhance one another
so
that as i look at 2022
you know one year at a time one step at
a time
that is the thing that i'm focusing on
so
that seems like what do you mean by that
so let me try to explain it
so one of the things that i've done
in trying to figure out
how these two things meet in me and
inform one another the skepticism and
the spirituality is looking for people
who i think are kind of writing that
line
looking for other people out there who
seem to embrace both of both of these
things right
so one person that i found and i can't
remember how i found
all the stuff i'm going to talk about so
so be it uh
but one person is uh maria popova
who runs the website the margin alien
which was formerly called brain pickings
she changed the name because i mean i
guess brain pickings sounds gross yeah i
i think she finally realized that
marginalia so so marginalian the margin
alien but so so mark i didn't wasn't
familiar with this term but marginalia
is like
you've got a book and there's margins
and you're like it's the stuff it's the
process it's the writing it's the notes
right okay that's marginalia it's stuff
that is peripheral to the stuff that
you're reading and then kind of the
connection between you and the material
that you're experiencing right okay you
know people who write a lot of stuff in
the margin yeah i usually just make
notes on my computer
and let me explain how she
describes her work so you can kind of
get a picture of her
she is
exploring what it means to live a decent
inspired
substantive
life of purpose and gladness
and this is from her website marginalia
is a record of my own becoming as a
person intellectually creatively
spiritually poetically drawn from my
extended marginalia on the search for
meaning across literature science art
philosophy and the various other
tendrils of human thought and feeling
a private inquiry i can't say that word
inquiry inquiry i can't say substantive
or inquiry
and she uses both of them in a very
short span of time
a private inquiry
irradiated by the ultimate question the
great quickening of wonderment that
binds us all what is all this
okay that is some beautiful language
she's a great writer i love her so it's
uh
it's kind of a fun it's heady but it's
uh it's open it's open-hearted it's it's
a
it's not it's not critical in her inner
mmm it is critical
i don't believe it is critical but it's
not closed okay okay so in her interview
with terry gross on on being uh she
talked about the bridge between cynicism
and hope
and i felt like
that's it
this bridge has slowly been constructing
itself maybe it's always been there
in me is just a part of the way that my
soul works right my brain whatever works
is that
you don't want to go off on the side of
cynicism
to the place where
you're just like
this you know
none of this matters and there is no
meaning in this just full stop that is a
position you could come to that's not a
position that i want to come to right it
doesn't sound appealing it sounds
it sounds depressing and all and also
it doesn't sound happy and maybe this is
not the rational me speaking but it
doesn't seem true to me either like my
experience with the world is not that
there is no meaning
regardless of how i feel about
the ultimate source of the meaning
the idea of a world without meaning just
it it doesn't compute because things
actually do mean things it stuff means
stuff to me you know what i'm saying
every day
i experience
a sense of purpose and meaning like it's
just intrinsic to who i am so the idea
that
beyond me in a greater sense there is no
meaning it's kind of like well there's
meaning right here on my little
individual level so it kind of makes
sense that there's meaning beyond my
individual level
i'm not a you know i haven't i i'm a i'm
a
a product of the harnett county public
school system and an engineering degree
so
i don't bring a lot of knowledge to any
of this stuff this is a lot of just
instinct so i haven't done a lot of
reading from people who know about this
stuff
just a disclaimer as i you know there's
no formal education that actually
informs any of the thoughts that i have
but
um
don't worry i'm here
yeah right thanks this really resonates
with me
this idea of this bridge between
synthesism and hope because you've got
that one side the cynicism sky the
skepticism side and then there's the
hopeful side that again
i can't just go off that side of the
bridge to the island of hope that just
exists in a place where you just live a
life of faith and none of the
none of the difficult inconvenient facts
or truths
matter and listen i'm not trying to care
this is for me i'm not saying that
people who are christians are on the
island of hope and have no discernment
i'm not saying that
i'm saying for me the reason i got off
of that island and the way that i was
experiencing it is because
in order to maintain the foundational
truth of christianity
i was i it became impossible for me to
maintain those truths and some other
truths that i felt like have become
inescapable and so i find myself in this
bridge between those two things but what
i'm finding is that's a really
interesting place to live and there's a
lot of people who've been living there
for a very long time
throughout history right i'm talking
about a couple of contemporary people
one of the things that maria talks about
she's so well read
um
and
you know in her book figurings which i
just started reading which is like
uh you know i go in terms of how long
the audible book is versus how many
pages there are but it's 21 hours so
this is where you buckle up buttercup
you know what i'm saying she's doing a
lot of figuring um
but she kind of she traces all kinds she
it's kind of like bill bryson's a
history of everything but with a sort of
a spiritual not even a spiritual just
more of like it isn't just the
information it's sort of like processing
and connecting information is
fascinating
um
but she's so well read and there's so
many people throughout time who have
struggled and wrestled with this stuff
and come to really interesting
conclusions or just really interesting
ways of living right
but the second person that i recently
came across that i want to talk about
and i want to talk about his book
um
found this book
show-and-tell i've got books he's
reaching for a book he's pulling it up
there it is spoiler alert this will be
my wreck this is uh richard holloway
stories we tell ourselves and there on
the bottom making meaning in a
meaningless universe
so um
this dude is freaking incredible let me
just say that i think i found one of my
favorite people on earth
really yes um so let me tell you about
richard holloway
let me hold the book i'll talk about his
book i'm just going to see if there's a
picture of him yep there it is okay he's
he's old he's he's old he's balding he's
wearing glasses he's very old i think
he's like
27.
he was the bishop of edinburgh from uh
1986 to 2000 and the primus of the
scottish episcopal church from 1992 to
2000.
he was
he was the primus huh premise yeah
wynonna got herself a big brown beaver
yeah yeah right
that's where primes comes from and he
left those roles in the year 2000
having become agnostic so he was in this
he was in the episcopal church and he
was a controversial very progressive
figure he like secretly married a gay
couple
uh which means performed
a wedding for a gay couple i was telling
my i was telling my kids about this i
was like this guy married a gay couple
in 1976
and shepard was like
he married a gay couple
like it was like it was a thrall
no that means he performed the wedding
and uh at a time when this was not very
accepted right so super progressive guy
who
has always sort of bucked against the
system and to the point where his
agnosticism made him have to leave the
church right all along the way he's
written all these incredible books such
as such a thoughtful person and then
he's written a bunch of books since
leaving the church i mean this is the
first one that i've read and i love
finding somebody this thoughtful and
also somebody who i feel like
man like if i was smarter and more
experienced
and could write then
these this is i it feels like so in tune
with the way that i see the world and
process the world obviously this guy
comes from a different time and place
um but rarely do do do you run into
somebody you're like oh man like the way
that you think about this is like
so resonant with the way that i think
about
truth
okay and i'm gonna ask a question that
you don't have to answer right now i
just wanna
i just want to hang it out there because
you've got a plan of how you want to go
through this but the question on my mind
is
and
before you brought up this book i was
thinking it and so i guess we are headed
in the same direction here
my question is
what's the difference between searching
for meaning and searching for truth and
when you say there's a tension between
um
or the last author you mentioned there
was cynicism
and
uh meaning right
it's like okay is
is well it was a cynicism a hope
cynicism and hope
and then you talked about like the
search for truth how is that different
than a search for meaning but
well that's i'm curious to me the
meaning is on the bridge between the two
stated simply the meaning is not on one
side the meaning is on the bridge
between the two
meaning is as it as the truth and the
hope
as i interact with
things that are true and truth exist
you know
technically objectively apart from
me
but hope is a very personal thing it's
it's it's
it's my sort of what i want to be true
and what i want my life to be like and
how i want to experience things
but i can only i personally can only do
that in the context of those things that
are true so being on that bridge for me
is where the meaning takes place
right because truth can be something
like
the wood that makes this table is poplar
okay i don't know if that's true or not
by the way that might be fake news
it might be oak i don't know a lot about
wood even though i have a it's part of
my brand i don't know a lot about it
i'd like to know i'd like to think that
i could smell it and know what it was
[Music]
is that truth meaningful to me
well it would be meaningful to me if i
was a if it was directly related to my
experience in other words if i had to
make a table
and i wanted it to look like this
then what kind of wood this was
would mean something to me as i apply it
in my experience
so you're saying there's not a
you're not making a choice between
i'm gonna opt i'm not i'm gonna give up
on a search for truth and i'm gonna now
embark on a search for meaning
because i do think that no no no our
experience has been we you've been
convinced that things were true in the
past
that now you believe aren't true
but you know you
you based your your life and your
meaning on what you believe to be true
so i think
i'm going to answer this question
directly okay
because i'm going to talk about what it
means to me and what like what the
pursuit of truth looks like and why i'm
i'm going to get to that so i'm going to
i'm going to answer that question
um
the thing that is so fascinating about
this guy besides just
oh
the things that he the things that have
influenced him to the point where he's
gotten are so similar and relatable to
the things that have gotten me to where
i am
just on a less
deep and educated degree
compared to him
is he talks a lot about
so this idea of stories we tell
ourselves
this is essentially
thinking about the human condition and
then
re-examining the bible itself
as a story
that
people told themselves so essentially
our experience with the world
every single thing that we experience
the colors that we
see
the sounds that we hear the things that
we feel
none of it is as it actually is right
you know colors don't actually exist we
the colors only exist in our mind
because this is certain wavelengths of
light that are reflecting off of
different things at different
frequencies and our brain is making
sense of it by creating a color
palette in in our in our brains right
same thing is true of the sounds that
are coming into my ear like my brain is
making
i am making meaning from my environment
right now every single thing that i
experience only makes sense from my
perspective because i'm here to
experience it right
and
the point he is making is that as people
experience things like in the case of
the bible and specifically the old
testament you've got the the the jews
who are experiencing all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] right and there's all kinds of
persecution and there's all kinds of
hardship that they're going through yeah
and at the time that they're writing the
bible
and they're right you know it wasn't
written at the time that it represents
it's not like
you know
what the torah which represents you know
which the tradition holds that moses
wrote it which is almost surely not true
and moses probably didn't exist but
setting that aside for a second it was
the idea that
it was written in a certain time but it
was written
about the past
it was it was writing about the past but
it was really also writing about what
they were currently experiencing right
so like looking he talks about the story
of daniel and how it related to what the
jews were going through at the time
under roman rule
wasn't necessarily so much about what
was happening in daniel's time
okay so more as a more as a parable
written right and then even he talks
about you know talks about the creation
story but also talks about jesus himself
right which again we don't really know
we don't actually know definitively too
much about the historical figure of
jesus or some people believe he didn't
even exist i think he did exist but i
think that the jesus that we have in the
bible
is a
um sort of idealized figure that was a
story that was that was told because it
was the story
that the people who were telling it
needed at the time
right
and this is true of every religious
writing
in in real and really everything that we
every story we tell ourselves right and
so he looks at the bible which is like
if you if you know the historical
context of what the the writers were
going through at the time if you know
the cultural context in which it was
written
it takes on a it illuminates the text in
a way and i'm not talking about like
back in the day like chaot k arthur
would come to campus crusades christmas
conference and talk to us about
you know her study bible and how and
because that's bringing an ideological
framework and applying it to the bible
from the outside and saying i'm coming
to this understanding that this is god's
inerrant word and i'm applying that
framework to it and then i'm drawing
conclusions from it
and then sometimes it'd be like oh and
here's a little cultural context if it
helps with our ideology right if it
reinforces what we're already thinking
i'm talking about taking the ideology
taking any preconceived commitment to
what this is throwing it out the window
and being and exploring it on a really
critical and really critical way not to
just tear it apart for the sake of
tearing it apart but to actually
figure out why they wrote it that way
and it becomes this thing that becomes
incredibly informative to me and this is
where i'm going to get to answering your
question
um
so that's my wreck i think i mean
i just think it's a great read i don't i
mean i don't know if you're a christian
or a former christian who thinks about
these things
read holloway's stories we tell
ourselves i'll just leave it at that
but
you know
there because there is a spectrum
okay let me get let me get there's so
much going on in my mind right now but
let me get to why i bought a bible
okay
so after reading and interestingly
the conclusion that he comes to at the
end which i don't think is any sort of
surprise
is that
after about 20 years of being outside of
the church
he's beginning to call himself a
christian again
really
yes
uh
so that's part of the story of this book
yeah okay
now does that mean he believes in god
probably not
uh
does that mean that he has changed what
he thinks about
the truth of the bible
like he has shifted his framework back
to believing that it's god's word no
it means it's a recognition that he
wants to identify with a story
specifically the story of jesus because
he feels like it is the it that story is
what he needs in his life
uh
again because i'm not trying to demean i
know this is uncomfortable for anybody
who
this would be have been very
uncomfortable for me to hear as a
christian
i'm not saying that jesus is essentially
frodo but i can't i am kind of saying
jesus is essentially frodo
so i don't mean that's mean he's just a
total fictional character and that's it
but i'm saying that like
conceivably
if i today said i'm starting a cult and
our re in our writings
are just the lord of the rings that's it
yeah okay
the trilogy looking good all three
even the hobbit yeah yeah and the hockey
the hobbit's kind of like the talmud
okay but we can get that as well
i think you're gonna have to throw on
the cimarrellian
simarillion is like the apocryphal
writings that's like the gospel the
gospel of thomas so yeah the son was
involved we don't really understand the
son had to finish it because he died i
think it's more of i think it's more of
just the commentary i think it
i haven't read it
don't make that face again
no one really what's the face that
that's it makes you look really old
really yeah you don't want to do that
you're getting too old to actually look
that up i look old yeah so
but if i told you and i have been
accused by many of potentially being a
call no one will read that book but it
can be part of it
everybody can just refer to it but no
one else i was starting a religion and
our scriptures were the lord of the
rings and various
you know other writings
you could probably piece something
together i could have a pretty awesome
religion yeah
because there's meaning in it just
because
middle earth doesn't exist doesn't mean
it's not
meaningful as a story and impactful and
actually life-altering and life-changing
if you say listen
in my friendship i need to be a sam
yeah you know what i'm saying i need to
i can aspire to be to learn from flawed
characters who uh embrace their
weaknesses and i'm not trying listen i'm
not saying that the bible is the
equivalent of i understand that there's
history there's real history in the
bible i understand that jesus was almost
most likely
a historical figure
and that
he said some of the things that are in
there
but but there's fictional elements of it
but what i'm saying it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter how for to me
if you believe that jesus died and rose
from the dead for your sins then it's
all it's got to be it's all got to be
true at least really big parts of it
have to be true i'm saying for me it
doesn't have to be true to be
meaningful and impactful and here's and
i don't think it's that
offensive to a christian because as a
christian
i i was like well that's what that's
that's what's true of the book of mormon
that's just made up by somebody
that's what we thought that's what
that's what we believed and that's what
you know but we many christians
currently believe so that's right but no
christian reads the book of mormon for
edification because it's such an
infringement on the true orthodox
christianity but they have to
acknowledge that other people
do an entire other religion yeah yeah
yeah although much of it is just like
copies straight from the bible right i
don't know much about it i don't know
much about it
i can you know i'm not gonna talk about
mormonism today
um
so
but i think that that you know
that is how i'm looking at the bible
because
using the lord of the rings is an
example
let's say i was raised in a tradition i
was raised in that cult
the lord of the rings cult the
fellowship is what we call it oh cool
which was a good name
and um
we all had rings
you know like there's so many awesome
things that you could do with this right
and like i was raised in that and i
developed i went through puberty in that
context columbus again i i came
to age
and into young adulthood
and then became a father and became
married all in the context of the
fellowship
and then one day i was like oh [ __ ] this
is just a made-up thing that some dude
wrote
oh gosh
and what and so then i have a choice
i could leave it
and say i never want to read anything
about that again
i don't even want to watch the movies i
don't even want to watch a movie with
elijah wood in it
or your loss
or i could say hold on hold on okay
i don't think it's true yes some dude
with three syllables for a name wrote it
but you know what it is the way it is or
really if you include the team it is why
i am who i am
so
can't i go back and read it again
can i go back and read it again over and
over again from a different perspective
and not just be like oh frodo's a real
guy and i've gotta i've got my own ring
and i gotta
be like why did he even write this like
this like why did he make these choices
because this is my dna has been probably
literally impacted by being
saturated with this yeah so i'm going to
go back and i'm not just going to
abandon it
i want to go back and examine it in a
new light with the new way that i think
about this
that's why i got a study bible and i got
the harper collins study bible which is
definitely not going to be recommended
in your churches unless you go to maybe
a mainline church because it's the
sort of like harper collins is a
publisher yeah yeah yeah so
but it's not like the zondervan study
bible is what i mean it's it's it's a
it's like a
secular critical okay
you know like dudes at the liberal
divinity schools harvard and yale etc
are the ones doing the commentary it's
not
the people who are writing the comment
my understanding is the people who are
doing the commentary
and the insights are not they don't come
to this with this with a the idea that
this is the
revealed word of god so there's not that
level of respect
they're just like this is exactly what
we think was being said this is why
these two texts don't are not the same
this is why this part's here this
so you're getting
full
uh unabashed sort of like critical
application of the scripture
hmm because i've already gone through
all the other yeah you know i've done
the i've done i've got all the study
bibles where they come at it with a
a conservative view to begin with i've
i've got those on my shelf in my in my
house so this is my first one that's
like okay this all the information that
would have made me squirm in the past
and made me question things so that's
just part of the deal here okay and and
so the holloway book is that what
ignited
your your um yeah
appetite
to you to go back to it
so because you're actually excited about
it it sounds like i am here well so
maria pope uh
she ignited that she gave me the
framework for thinking about the bridge
between cynicism and hope and realizing
that oh i've been going back and forth
and like
live in the confusion right live on the
bridge
and under and be like embracing both of
these things at the same time that's
exciting that's where the meaning comes
from then you find this guy from my
exact tradition not exact tradition he's
episcopal but
exact disposition and appreciation of
these stories but also comes just a lot
of the same conclusions that i've come
to in terms of agnosticism
uh and then he's basically like oh and
by the way because he's like these are
the stories that people live by and then
at the end he's like the story i live by
and he basically says i live according
to the story of jesus and here's why
it's a great chapter
it's not going to be as it doesn't
nothing is as definitive and like neatly
tied up as we as former religious
conservatives are
uh gonna be okay with you know what i'm
saying like we're still learning to live
in the
the tension
but
uh but yeah that was where i was like i
gotta get this i got and he also he
references like some really good
scholars and i looked up those scholars
and then those scholars had written
stuff about he i think he actually uh he
actually references maybe the study
bible in the book anyway
that's how i got to getting the bible
and you told me that you just got the
bible so i assume you haven't five weeks
because apparently study bibles are
especially like critical study bibles
not into high demand it's written it's
used by atheist scribes
and they begin writing the moment you
you order them
basically
and they're kind of just it doesn't
really matter to them they're just kind
of going off of
memory and they're looking at the last
one but they're not i don't really know
right
so they're not trying there's nothing
really to preserve
one one of the things that um i kind of
skipped over a little bit that i want to
go back to
um
one of the big the middle section of
this book
he talks a lot about william james who
is you know really like the father of
modern psychology in a lot of ways i've
heard a number of people mention him um
michael pollan talks about william james
in his um
not his most recent book but the
previous book your mind what is it
i can't remember
not the most recent one but the previous
one how to change your mind how to
change your mind he talks about william
james and he had an experience when he
was in michael pollan like i think when
he did mushrooms he had a
uh he had an experience where
he quoted william james as he was trying
to sort of quantify his experience
where he said i don't know what i think
about anything
metaphysical in the world and all that
stuff beyond my own experience but
as william james said
this experience has caused me to
for it has caused me to i'm forbidding
myself to settle
my accounts with reality
this whole idea of closing your accounts
or settling your accounts with reality
resisting that urge because it is the
human it is the human disposition to be
like can i just get all this stuff
wrapped up this philosophical [ __ ] can i
just get it wrapped up boxed up and set
it in my garage and just be like i
that's what i think about that and i
don't want to keep going back to it
because it's tiresome
and
whether you're an atheist you know and
you say
i don't believe in anything beyond the
natural world and all these religious
people are just fantasy thinkers or
whatever case closed i'm done that's
what i think for the rest of my life or
whether you're just like i subscribe to
the religion of my youth and that's it
and i don't confuse me with any
information that's going to make this
difficult
there's two two extremes he's basically
saying don't settle your accounts with
reality and the way that he's doing that
is by
leaning into the story of jesus and
saying listen i'm not trying to say that
this isn't true or is it true i'm
letting its meaning permeate me as i
study it and i i read it
you know what if there's a god maybe a
god will work through that you know i
mean i'm sure there are christians out
there it'll be like well at least he's
reading the bible again
god can work through that and maybe
they're right one i i'm not trying to
say that they're not
yeah let's talk about your plans you
finally got in the bible is it leather
bound is it hard it's hard okay nice is
it got nice feet right it doesn't have
my name on it now because this is
i mean
this is a study exercise this is not
this is not reading a book or listening
to an audio book
you know this is
a study bible you actually
anticipate that you're going to sit down
and have a quiet time
well that would be probably uh not the
greatest way to describe it
because a quiet time
or a devotional
is more like a
is more than that word
and
more like it's like a prayer kind of
thing
uh no i'm not i'm not going i'm not
saying i'm reading the bible what are
you gonna do
um
i haven't exactly figured out
i think you're not what i i cut you off
you said i'm not reading the bible as a
communion with god
yeah i'm not doing that right okay so
you're doing it as i'm not doing that
okay what i'm saying is like right
that's that's not
i'm trying to i'm trying to i'm not
going in
i have found that not being afraid of
whatever's around the corner is the best
way to live
okay okay
every time
i start getting like buildings like
what's around that corner that's no fun
and it just keeps you from going around
the corner just go around the damn
corner
what's the worst that could happen
somebody just punches you right in the
face you get shot yeah okay okay
describe that corner like there's a
there's a study bible on the corner like
to me there is no corner
so what i'm saying
i'm trying to eliminate the corners in
my life right and so what i'm saying is
that
i think i want to develop some kind of
plan with it so that there is uh
there's a path right but i think the
path is loosely
read through the entire bible oh from
beginning from beginning to end no don't
don't that's not a good plan
it doesn't i'm not i'm not talking about
the bible in a year which i've done that
i'm not talking about that plan
i'm not talking about like the bible in
a year where it's just like oh i'm
talking about like
there's a bookmark in this bible
and it moves when i read it
it's going to get to leviticus pretty
quick yeah yeah i understand that but
what i'm going to be most interested in
this may this may disappoint some of the
christians listening
is going to be what they say about it
right i've read i've read leviticus i
have shlogged through it
um and i'm not saying i'm not going to
but i'm going i think that
it's actually when you when you believe
that the bible is god's word and you get
to leviticus you're like really god you
know what i'm saying like if you bring
that perspective to it you're like what
you said these things like oh i want to
melt my face off i just didn't know what
you were going to say but i didn't think
you were going to say i'm going to read
through the bible from so i thought
maybe you'd say i'm going to you know
i'm going to do something i'm going to
start with
jesus
and then i must and then i might skip
around i might do a little job i might
like get a new perspective on creation
yeah well here's what i'm saying i think
i'm going to start with genesis because
not just because it's first but i've
always been fascinated with it and it is
you know
my difficulties with trying to reconcile
it that makes sense to me and then when
i get to that i might be like hey let's
go i'm going to go to the new testament
i'm just what i'm getting at is i want
to go through the whole thing
at least book by book
and it might be oh i'm going to do some
old new then do some new whatever i'm
not saying it has to be straight through
in order what i'm saying is that
the only plan is that i have the bible
and i will read it
and i may go long periods of time
without reading it but because i'm not
doing it out of a religious conviction
it doesn't matter
yeah so i just want to let you off the
hook here that's like
you're not making a commitment to read
through the entire world but what i'm
saying is if you're not yourself to me
or a year from now a year from now if my
update might be hey i'm still in genesis
i like
it's not i'm not setting up an
obligation i'm just saying oh
the epiphany that has happened is that
there still is a way to experience this
book that was so formative for me
there's a new way to engage it that can
be exciting because the thing is is that
when i hear people start talk when he
got to that section of the book and he
started talking about
what the guy who i mean it was probably
a guy just because it was so long ago
and that's patriarchy um who wrote
genesis
like
you know which was probably an
adaptation of an oral tradition so you
go back to the first time the guy
started like telling the fight the story
around the fire about you know where we
come from well in the beginning
you know it's like
it's a dramatic pause and so as i what
make this up as i make
he actually as i tell myself a story
well that's the answer you're gonna tell
us that's the interesting thing he says
isn't it kind of
this is implication isn't it kind of
awesome to think about it being a
campfire story that a guy was just kind
of just like i see the way things are
and i'm going to kind of make try to
make sense of it like that's powerful
to it's the same way that if i was like
i've gotten really interested in this
um ancient tribe that has this
incredible tradition and they've got
these these scriptures and i'm i'm
interested in that anthropological kind
of stuff okay so reading it in that way
so there's a yeah but because it's so
applicable to me personally my
background there's this
i don't know there's a lot of motivation
right now who knows what will happen in
a month but there's a historical and
critical analysis that i assume that the
commentators
who are
right making this a study bible they're
actually writing little snippets and
you know
giving their commentary on these
passages
that they're
do you know yet if their main goal is to
illuminate meaning for the reader or if
it's to provide critical analysis so
what's your approach there it's
definitely not to
again
i think
a lot of these questions that you're
asking and i understand what you're
asking are coming from
the framework that we bring to any of
this type of thinking about things right
well i'm also just thinking practically
once you get this study bible from a
totally different perspective that you
it could be a temptation to latch onto
the criticism of it and to tear it down
versus define meaning in it from a
different vantage point well again i
still think that's coming from your old
framework but here's what i'm going to
say because what we always assumed is
that the guys who were quote unquote
being critical about the bible didn't
respect it or just outright didn't
believe it yes so that there so we we're
so binary in our thinking you're either
all in or you're an atheist and that's
just not how that's not how many people
at all actually operate right so i think
that these you think you take you know
most
what we would have called liberal
scholars which i would just call
critical academic scholars
you don't make the decision to be like
what am i going to do for a living i'm
going to be a bible scholar if you hate
it
that's the most ridiculous thing i've
ever heard in my life
that you would decide to devote your
entire life it they'd be like i'm a i'm
a biologist but damn it i hate animals
you know what i'm saying it's like it
doesn't make any sense it's people who
are fascinated with religious thinking
religious tradition and they're probably
fascinated by it because that's their
own disposition as well i think the term
literary criticism is ringing in my ears
and i might just have because of the
reasons that you stated i have a uh
i'm applying the wrong definition of the
word criticism to whether it's just
ripping something down but i am curious
in this in this these bible snippets
is there like
edifying
no of course not think about this so but
then that's going to be your task right
because you said that's you
you're doing it to that's to get some
meaning from it right well i'm not no
i'm not taking any agenda into it
okay
what i'm saying is that
leaning further into the truth
with the only intention to be to get
further and cl further and closer to the
truth
the meaning will happen i don't have to
make it happen i don't have to seek it
what i'm saying and i'm going to talk
i'm going to get there
i guess i wonder is that an academic
meaning or a spiritual meaning
like what are you what are you looking
for here i'm saying that there's no
difference
i'm saying that you've created a
dichotomy in your own mind and i have to
and most people have as well that
there's two types of truth there's truth
that is somehow not spiritual and there
is truth that is spiritual
all truth is spiritual my definition of
spirituality is all-encompassing right
it is anything that enriches and
enhances and deepens my human experience
and that may include
metaphysical things that i can't quite
nail down i am open to that but it may
just include
learning a fact about this table
and so
i'm trying to break down that dichotomy
between what and i and i'm gonna take a
little sidebar here to talk about
another book that i know you're familiar
with and then come back at the end to
talk specifically about that
the idea of what leaning in the truth
looks like
beyond
um beyond the bible
because because i don't believe that you
know
i want i'm i'm leaning in the truth
about the bible right because i don't
see the bible as
true in this in in any particular sense
any particular like religious dogmatic
sense
but i'm like oh but i can learn this
historical thing about the jews who who
wrote it at this point or the guys in
the new testament who wrote this
you know i'm gonna okay
let's this is i should have teased this
because um it's so tease work
there's another book i want to talk
about and then i'll bring it all back
together at the end
this book
before you lose your faith
deconstructing doubt in the church is a
book um
it is a compilation uh all about
deconstruction
uh from different authors a couple of
months ago we saw mythical beasts tweet
this at us
and i had not heard about it until then
and there's a reason that they they
tweeted us but it was particularly it
had been published
on for almost a year it was published
i'm surprised that we hadn't heard about
it until it was published like the
middle of the middle of 2021 i think
okay by the gospel coil we heard about
it weeks ago gospel coalition is a uh a
group of is a you know there are the
reformed tradition
uh pastors and churches kind of a
network
um
they publish things there's a website
they comment on things
there's articles at the website i think
when we when we went public with our
deconstruction they talked about us a
little bit they're very very much
evangelical yeah yeah and very reformed
which both our our background is
reformed evangelical so
we're very familiar with uh this way of
thinking
but in the introduction
the first thing written in this book
this is the guy who edited it uh ivan
mesa i think i'm saying that right
um
the first sentence in the introduction i
had never heard of red and link
i have that's me okay yes
you're starting with like a a
a backhanded that's not even backhanded
well it gets worse so like who are these
no
i don't know if you pick up something
else i never heard of retin link the duo
behind good mythical morning their daily
youtube show with more than 16 million
subscribers and ear biscuits hey we're
doing it right now their podcast until i
learned of their public deconstruction
story the two of them who as of december
2020 are the fourth highest youtube
earners making 20 million a year with a
little footnote here
shared about uh how they move from crew
staffers and missionaries to unbelievers
or as rhett now describes himself a
hopeful agnostic
uh
okay
and never heard of these guys but
they're rich well but not only that if
you look at the footnote next to
uh
how much money we make a year
it says
rupert neat ryan
oh rupert need i guess this is who wrote
it
ryan kajii nine earns 29.5 million a
year ah and so so
i i i don't know if this was the
implication but it was almost like to
put things in perspective
a nine-year-old makes more money than
they
do know it's like yeah why was that the
footnote i don't know it feels a little
like a backhanded thing but i'm gonna
give you the benefit of the doubt and
say that it wasn't that it was just for
context i don't know um
you know what this book is i've read
i've read i'm actually i'm three
quarters of the way through i i wanted
to get completely done before this
uh we actually talked about doing like a
whole episode that was just about this
but i just think that that's kind of
boring and lolita insider i have a copy
and so i'm gonna talk about this next
week okay so gospel coalition we've sent
you guys some money
um we bought two little reluctantly but
here's the fascinating thing about this
book to me but we're so rich right yeah
so rich i mean we're not as rich as that
nine-year-old but uh yeah i wish i could
be as rich as ryan but here's the thing
ryan toy review um
this was such a fascinating book to me
again every chapter is by a different uh
author
but he goes on to say i mean you should
finish the introduction well the
comedians have for years been a staple
in many homes with children and young
adults with videos ranging from epic rap
battles to testing the world's hottest
peppers getting shot with nerf guns so
it wasn't surprising that their public
announcement unsettled the faith of many
um
and then he goes on to talk about other
people who've deconstructed gen hat
maker joshua harris
um
what is deconstruction kind of setting a
little bit
the book
kind of takes every element of
deconstruction whether that be
uh and first of all let me say
there's a lot that i kind of agree with
not i don't agree with the conclusions
but i agree with some of the
observations right there and and the
fascinating thing for me was this is a
book that in an alternate universe i
have written a chapter in maybe i'm
giving myself a little too much credit
and they wouldn't have accepted me but
in an alternate universe we never left
the church and of course we did what we
always do and we try to
just
succeed as hard as we can in whatever
we're doing
i definitely thought that
uh in the parts that i've read
that
you know because each chapter is written
by a different person it's basically an
essay that where they choose
every angle they can come up with to to
undermine the whole process the process
of spiritual deconstruction and in the
world where we never left staff with
crew and we de we are you know our
ministry developed into like directly
combating deconstruction in this culture
because we were always about being on
the front lines what's the biggest thing
that young people are dealing with let's
take that and let's take them out of the
knees you know that was the way that we
thought about about this stuff and so it
was fascinating to be like well that's
what i would have said well that's
exactly what i would have said that's
exactly how i would have said that
now the parts that i agree with when it
talks about um
you know uh
there's a chapter that talks about
disenculturation this the idea that um
did you deconstruct christianity or do
you did you deconstruct the culture
cultural context for your christianity
and and so yes there's a lot of negative
stuff about evangelical culture
you can
be critical of that and you can
deconstruct that but don't throw the
baby out with the bathwater the baby
being jesus and he was a baby yeah and
ricky bobby prayed directly to him
um
and so i hey listen i agree with that i
agree with that now that my conclusion
is nothing rather attend to talladega
nights called cult
than a lord of the rings called as much
as i love you and the movie is the is
the material and maybe the director's
commentary but
um
i agree with that and the reason i
didn't it doesn't change my mind is
because
that's not why i deconstructed i i
for me the problem was the foundational
truths of scripture i just i failed to
believe them but there's there's a
there's a chapter about
the tendency for people to
move from one fundamentalism to another
fundamentalism very very common in
deconstructing yeah is that you leave
sort of a fundamentalist christian
mindset and you move into a progressive
christian
mindset and a lot of times the
progressive christian mindset and the
progressive left in general can have the
same sort of inflexible
fundamentalist thinking that you have on
the on the right i completely agree with
that i don't like ideological thinking i
don't like group think i don't like
policing the way people think about
things and the way people talk about
things and you see that on the left just
as much you see it on the right so
i will say this entire thing i believe
is written to people who are not
deconstructing it is written to give to
people who you're afraid might to
bolster them against ever
considering
spiritual deconstruction it bolsters
that
i mean yeah these are people who haven't
it's for people who haven't gone over
the edge yet really
uh i you know there's there's a there's
one about race which talks about yes
acknowledges racism in the church but
says hey listen just because people have
abused and misused christianity in the
name of evil and racism doesn't mean
that you should deconstruct i agree with
all that but the one that's getting
people off of the past the one it also
talks about how scientism is the word
they use but basically science can't
explain
morality um which i think that you know
there's great natural explanations for
morality that they kind of just gloss
over but anyway
i agree with some i disagree with some
obviously i disagree with the main
conclusion of the book but the thing i
wanted to talk about and then bring it
back to how it relates to kind of how
i'm moving forward in 2022
is the first chapter uh
which is written by a guy named kevin
watts kevin wax these
way back to truth ivan mesa and trevon
wags you got cool names it's coming from
two guys with cool names so congrats for
that
um i will cite chapter three
deconversion is not as counter cultural
as you think so
hey this is this isn't the cool thing to
do yeah so let which i agree i agree
with that yeah don't
don't do it because it's cool
uh so
in the first chapter
deconstruction is characterized as
essentially
a selfish act right rather than a
thoughtful reconsideration of one's
faith
let me just i'm going to read some
quotes i'm not i'll just put the book
down because i've written them down here
what if you are not the dispassionate
pursuer of facts you perceive yourself
to be but instead are shaped by
assumptions and presuppositions that
you've never challenged
another quote
i don't believe you are faithless your
faith has merely shifted away from god
and his word and towards yourself and
the story you've crafted in which you
now find meaning
and significance or which you've crafted
in which you now find meaning and
significance
and finally you
are no longer sure about the god of
christianity are you sure of the self
you place at the center of your
deconversion story
this is a
very common um
way of seeing people who are
deconstructing this is how i saw people
who were deconstructing before i could
deconstruct it when we had friends who
started to waver
we would say listen man you're
you're making god in your own image
rather than realizing that you're made
in his image you're you're picking and
choosing you're making a religion
you're becoming your own god and that's
what deconstruction ultimately is right
i understand why why you believe that
but i find this to be pretty ironic for
a number of reasons so
first thing is this is this is a very
effective strategy for people who are
deconstructing or people who are
thinking about deconstructing
because in my experience deconstructing
people tend to be very thoughtful and
questioning of themselves
i had this exact same concern for years
but i find that most deconstructing
christians have a lot of doubt in their
own reasoning and that's precisely what
led them to where they are they began to
take a critical look not simply a
christianity itself but also to their
adherence to it so in other words the
deconstruction process began as
self-doubt or at least that was a part
of it so
when you begin to think i remember
writing and i talked about this in my
deconstruction story i specifically
wrote that i did not just want to become
my own god i did not want to replace i
didn't want to make god in my own image
i didn't want to make a god that i was
comfortable with deconstructing people
are very conscious of this and that's
why when you tap into that it is a very
effective strategy to get them to come
back into the fold because they're very
conscious of being self-centered
and
relying on their own instincts because
that's the thing that they begin
questioning that even begins the process
to begin with yeah and you you know what
that effective strategy is
shame it's one word it is shame yeah
slathered on
yeah i agree with that
um
but maybe
this is a little bit more dismissive i
don't disagree with it i've i
i'm excited no no no no i feel like i
completely i'm moving i'm moving to the
next
um
i'll talk about it my other issue with
this is it assumes that the
non-deconstructing christian is the more
selfless person right
uh they are not following their own
instincts but rather submitting to and
following god
now
as someone who doesn't who no longer
believes that that's how the world works
and i don't actually believe that
you as a christian have the have the
spirit of god in you in a way that i
don't and you have discernment from him
that that i don't i actually think that
we're both doing the same thing which
could be characterized as selfish if
that's the word you want to use for and
that is
we as a product of our environment
our circumstances and our genetics
all factors
we are making a decision about pretty
much everything that we think is the
best for us right that's what humans do
we take all the information that we have
and all the instincts that we have and
we just make a decision that we feel is
best for us at the time
now
christians and specifically the guys who
wrote this book
are basically farming that out which i
believe is a decision that they've made
to make a decision to say that they
believe the bible is an errand word of
god that they're going to be christians
this is what they're going to believe
that they're going to be reformed
whatever it is and then they're saying
that this is god and this is me
submitting to god it's a sort of a jedi
mind trick of farming out their own
choices to an entity that is god
that's how i see that right i think i'm
doing the same thing i'm just not
farming it out i am saying yeah i am
making this decision and i know that a
lot of this may not even be decisions
that i have control over because
i don't even know how i feel about free
will and determinism and all that stuff
you know i'm am i just a sub a victim of
my own circumstances and genetics i
don't know maybe but it doesn't feel
that way
but
so i take issue with that fundamentally
that they are somehow different but also
again it's sort of broadly categorizing
people who deconstruct as people who are
selfish and self-centered
whether you that's the implication it's
also kind of just explicitly said here
but the most interesting thing about
this to me
um
is that
for me personally
the thing that was the most difficult
process a difficult element of my
deconstruction process was the
de-centering of myself
let me explain that
de-centering myself from the story of
the universe right
now
this is an old story this is how
christianity has interacted with new
uh new facts
for a very long time right the church is
always the last people to get on board
with unsettling facts that challenge
their perspective
the heliocentric uh
uh view of the world meaning that the
sun or the view of the solar system
meaning that the sun is the center of
our solar system
versus the geocentric
view which is that the earth is in the
middle and everything's rotating around
it of course for many generations
everyone believed that the earth was
central because of course this is uh
this way this is what we see this is
from our perspective we're the middle of
this that's what the bible taught very
clearly
and it's what the church believed for a
really long time
and the reason that it took them
hundreds of years to accept it and
people were killed because of this
is fundamentally because it's taking
humans off of the center off of the
throne of the universe and it's saying
no no no this is you're not as special
as you thought you were you might just
be
a lucky branch on the evolutionary tree
right because that's the second piece of
it is evolution which the church has
still not accepted right
um some christians do believe it right
and to me this is so significant because
believing in evolution was the first
card to fall for me now disclaimer i
know that there's lots of christians who
believe in evolution however most don't
and many of the ones that do
uh
i don't really think have followed
followed it to its logical conclusion
and what it actually means to how it
relates to the creation story and that
kind of thing but
you know
this was so difficult for me because
as a christian
everything exists for you right now yes
and god right but god set you apart as
special you're not related to the
animals you're a special creation the
animals exist for your pleasure god's
pleasure but yeah but your pleasure i
mean that's what that's what genesis
talks about the the earth was made for
adam and then oh adam
these animals are not good enough let me
give you one that you can actually have
sex with here's a woman
you know um and so all these things are
created
so you can have dominion over them and
then everything the entire
sort of
ancient near eastern view of the world
and the cosmos of it being very very
small and it being this disk of an earth
with a dome over it and the waters below
and the waters above and the firmament
in between
it brought everything down and very very
close they looked at the dome and they
saw the stars hanging from it and it was
just i don't know that's
just right up there if i had a if i had
a
if i was strong enough i could throw a
rock and hit it you know what i'm saying
it was small and you were big
and with every sin
every successive
scientific revelation we get smaller and
smaller and more insignificant in the
scheme of things and that is very
uncomfortable for a christian mindset
you know christians
many christians don't want to believe
are very resistant to the idea of aliens
not because
we haven't necessarily seen any
which is the reason i don't know if they
exist
but because what does that mean about
did they have another jesus did jesus go
to them is that the other sheep that
they're talking about in the bible i
have other sheep well it must be aliens
you know
you gotta you gotta fit it into your
world view so
i think what i'm saying is that
the traditional christian perspective is
actually more self-centered than a
perspective that sees humans as another
part of the universe
now i'm not talking about individuals
i'm not saying that christians are more
selfish than non-christians i'm not
saying that non-christians are more
selfish than christians i think that
your level of selfishness is largely
unrelated to your religious convictions
and conclusions there's a lot of selfish
inside and outside of the church and
there's lots of reasons that contribute
to people being selfish right
but i'm saying that the philosophy of
christianity is a more human-centered
philosophy than a naturalistic worldview
the naturalistic world view puts you in
concert puts you in connection
interconnection with everything else
there was this there was a big bang at
the beginning and matter has organized
itself or was organized by some entity
that i can't really identify into what
it is now but we are stardust and so is
the elephant and the earth isn't really
any more mine than it is the elephants
right and that's a and just because i'm
smarter and just because i have more
self-awareness than the elephant i
should be able to do whatever i want to
no
so
the philosophy
is more selfish
and it just feels like there's a
complete failure to see that in this
accusation that the person who begins to
break away from that traditional
orthodox way of seeing the world
christian way of seeing the world is
somehow selfish and i'm like hey man
the most difficult part of this process
for me was realizing that i wasn't as
special as i thought i was
so it kind of so that that specific
accusation
rings very very hollow to me and is a
pretty dismissive
you know
along the way
but
i want to bring it back bring it back to
what i was talking about um earlier
and that is this idea
that leaning into uncomfortable truths
rather than recoiling from them
is always more illuminating and
ultimately more spiritual and i want to
use evolution as an example again
you know when i was a christian
in in in before i started believing in
evolution
i saw evolution as first a desperate
attempt to explain the universe apart
from god right it was like you got to
come up with something so maybe they
just happened spontaneously and
everything's related and well i don't
know making stuff up right
um
i also saw it as a direct threat to the
way that i understood the world
right i saw it as a direct threat in
terms of the veracity of scripture but
also a direct threat in terms of
my place in the universe as this is for
me the world is about you know god
created humans to be in relationship
with him and everything else that is
under that is for is for us
and i first of all never really
understood it i never honestly
considered it
right and then when i finally did
honestly consider it it was the first
card it was the everything began to fall
apart
but on the other side of it
that truth
that truth of the interconnectedness of
all things of every single thing that i
can touch and see in the world literally
being related to me every animal that i
can see
literally being my cousin
that's a life-changing truth
that that's a life-changing truth
that sense of interconnectedness changes
the way that you interact with other
people it changes the way that you
interact with the environment the world
it changes the way you see yourself it
changes the way that you you see the
responsibility that we have to to
maintain this whole thing that we've got
going and the fragile fragile fragility
of it right so
i think what i'm saying is that
you were saying what what is it
what is this learn what is this leaning
into the truth are you leaning into the
truth for meaning
what i'm saying is that leaning into the
truth
for whatever reason
there's going to be meaning that comes
from that
especially if that's just your
disposition is to find meaning in things
right we're meaning makers we can't help
it
from the very beginning of our
consciousness we've had this we went
from thinking that there was
uh
something moving in the bushes to
you know ascribing agency to things like
we
we're like okay it didn't rain today
well god must be upset with us
let's dance let's
let's pray oh it rained it must have
been because we danced it must have
become because we prayed
this is what we do we can't help it we
can't help but be meaning makers it's in
it's in our blood it's in our dna
it's who we are
and so
what i'm saying is that i want to learn
more and lean more into truth
and not because i'm looking for meaning
but because truth is interesting to me
right knowing more about something and
having it more accurately described and
not being scared of where it's leading
has only been a positive thing for me
and i use that
finally accepting evolution and then
being like okay well what's next my my
whole process of deconstruction was kind
of like a card would fall and i would be
like oh [ __ ]
and i'd be like okay well god you're in
control you have the power to stop this
at any point but i'm gonna turn over the
other card you know and i would just
keep going and keep going
on the back end of that what i found is
that
the process of deconstructing and the
truths that i now hold to
have been some of the most beautiful and
life-altering are they as orienting as
christianity was no they're not as
orienting because that's what a
religious system does is it orients your
thinking and it systematizes your
thinking in a way that brings a certain
level of comfort and control
you don't get that when you step outside
of a religious framework i'm very
willing to admit that
but again being on that bridge between
hope and cynicism
i think that's where the that's where
the meaning happens
and
now whereas because like yeah i i've
accepted
the interconnectedness of all things
i've accepted that i am a pr you know
i'm i am a lucky branch on the
evolutionary tree a couple of things
could have gone a little bit differently
and we could be a couple of neanderthal
sitting here talking right
it's it it was a matter of circumstance
and that's okay
that doesn't make that actually makes
in my mind that makes this even more
significant i'm like well damn it's like
we got to this point
like we're here at the end of all this
crazy [ __ ] that's been going on we're
here right now
experiencing life
being able to consider it and look back
on it
like that's significant
and that it's meaningful
and as it relates to the bible
it's like okay well hey
i'm not going at this thinking that i've
got to maybe i'll find god in the letter
in the words of the bible well maybe i
will i'm not saying i don't want to be
close to either either
side
but what i'm saying is that there's a
whole layer of truth to the bible that i
never considered because i was afraid of
it if you started talking about critical
about the bible
it was so and so i just and then when i
finally deconstructed i was like that
stuff is triggering i can't read the
bible without getting triggered and
getting uncomfortable so i'm just going
to put it on the shelf and not read it
for a few years
and now i'm saying no i'm going back and
i'm saying i'm not afraid of any i'm not
afraid i just i'm just going and i'm
just looking at it and i'm looking at
everything you can know about it
and
i
the truth is gonna will appear you know
the truth and the meaning will come
i don't have to control it
i don't have to come in with this
preconceived
idea and
last thing i'll say is i understand that
this is a
this whole process this whole
conversation this incredibly privileged
uh viewpoint right you know that's one
of the things that you read about when
you when you think about the the
the jewish people who wrote the bible
and what they were going for going
through
they were going through a bunch of man
like it's and this is true of basically
anybody who's
putting together a religious tradition
is usually out of necessity
and out of trying to somehow get through
what they were
going through
and i mean and also you think about
african-american spirituality right and
you think about how there's this really
ironic thing that happened where
uh
you know african slaves took on the
religion of their oppressors
in many different ways and there's black
christian spirituality now
and they have a tradition kind of all
and actually talks a little bit about
this in this book
but a tradition of their own
that
considering that and like sitting there
and deconstructing that that's a
position of extreme privilege for a
couple of guys who are number four on
the forbes money list yeah just under
that nine-year-old
i have the ability
to just sit here and be like i don't
have hardship in my this is a
philosophical exercise for me i
recognize that it's not one in which i'm
going through this incredibly difficult
thing personally where i'm crying out to
god right
right now i live in such a position of
privilege and excess
that i can
explore these things
like a college professor
and so i'm not saying that this is
something that i am trying to apply to
everybody and everybody should do like
for some people are going through
something so difficult
and the way that they see and understand
jesus has been indispensable for them
i'm not trying to take that away from
them i'm not interested in taking that
away from them
you know just like i'm not interested in
taking changing the minds of the
christians that i'm still friends with
they want to hear what i have to say
about that or what i think about some
conclusion they come to i'm happy to
discuss it but this isn't designed to
deconstruct other people's
faith i'm just saying
this is how it happened for me this is
how it continues to happen for me and i
recognize that i'm able to do this just
simply because i'm in a very
specific privileged position
yeah i think people
some
people may
write you off and say okay you're
basically saying
you don't have any need for jesus
like as a personal savior so like
i don't expect rhett to get anything
from him going back to the bible
especially that version of the bible but
you know what it's less about the
version of the bible and more about like
what his
what his needs are and and is he open to
having those met i think is is the
criticism that you know that's the story
that
people will tell from one vantage point
and i and you know and i'll go back to
what i said before
when the the accusation of this is just
a self-centered pursuit
i i know for a fact that this
conversation is only going to reinforce
that perspective because that's what you
think
my perspective is that we're all doing
that
we're all
synthesizing and making personal
decisions
and
there's lots of different factors it's
very complicated and it's very muddy
and i'm not going to fault you for
coming and i have done that i'll stand
up and say i have faulted people for com
the thing i will say is if you subscribe
to a system or you actively
are
discriminating against or
belittling
marginalized people i'm going to stand
up for those marginalized people right
that's one place that i'm not going to
compromise but when it comes to your
personal choices about what you end up
thinking about the bible and what you
think about jesus it's just like
i know that i ca you can't make someone
believe you can't make me believe
something i can't make you believe
something beliefs are things that happen
spontaneously based on circumstances
you know
um
which
you know i think is ironic in one sense
because this is all you know this whole
thing is being written from the reformed
perspective and the very fir
introduction talks about the parable of
the sower being a framework for
for understanding this and it's just
like there's a part of me that's just
like hey uh
if you really are reformed and you
believe that there are some people who
are elected to
be children of god and some people who
are not by the way the vast majority of
people um well
why write this book at all
that's why i just say that in like a
tweet
you know but
i digress
well and i'll i'll share next week um
yeah you've given me it there's a number
of things i want to springboard off of
that you're going to buy a bible
uh you should buy it you should order it
now it's going to take a month and a
half to get here
i can photocopy mine but that would
probably take you i have i have a few
i have i have a few at home still thank
you
and thanks for sharing i think this is
uh this is good you know you didn't you
know you didn't give me enough answers
to know what i'm going to do with the
rest of my spiritual life
you know because all i do is just
whatever you tell me
that's what people say about me
well but here's the thing i'm coming up
with things that i know you're not going
to do
that's right that is that if you're not
going to read the book you're not going
to remember
this bible i am not
so you're on your own now oh yeah yeah i
love it my wreck is uh
richard holloway stories we tell
ourselves love this guy check out
marginalia as well i think it's the
marginalian.com and listen
read read this book you know send the
gospel well maybe find a way to steal
something no i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding
uh i i think that if you are
this before you lose your faith is sort
of a fascinating study of the way that
the evangelical church is
trying to process what's happening
and
it's like i said i think this is about
the best attempt that can be made right
now to
attack this thing from every single
uh angle
but it's kind of amazing how
ineffective it is for me personally i'm
sure it's gonna be very effective for
some people i'm just saying that like if
you're at a place that i'm at right now
it's just like oh wow well it's again
it's it's not after you've lost your
faith
you lose your faith yeah yeah i agree
and so before you fall backwards into
something that you're probably going to
hit your head
uh on read this book that's what the uh
yeah listen i i i
i'm not making light of the people who
wrote this book because
like i said for a fact i don't know what
i think about the multiple
uh you know universes but
multiple worlds theory whatever you call
it but there is a rhett who
tried to maybe got rejected but tried to
contribute to this book definitely in
another you know absolutely and so i do
not fault you for this is exactly what i
would be doing if i had not left my
faith
i'd be trying like crazy to justify the
way i think about it and trying to keep
the youth
from thinking differently and that's
what this is
hashtag air biscuits
let us know what resonated with you from
uh rhett's update
thanks man
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]